mr president what will it take for you
to send the polish mix that president
zielenski is asking for
i'm not going to comment that right now
i'm not going to come here
president biden shooting down the idea
of getting ukraine mig fighter jets
while announcing a new security
assistance package
pledging 800 million dollars in military
equipment including drones and better
anti-aircraft systems republicans asking
what took so long
provide them the migs
provide them the planes where they can
create a no-fly zone provide them the
armament that they need to continue
to fight a
war that they did not create the burden
of proof should be on us about why we
wouldn't supply everything they need we
need to hit back
and we can do that by supplying them the
arms they need but we need to do it now
all the way through this whole process
president biden has been either had to
be pushed or prodded or pulled across
the line we need the action now
you know it's hard sandra with the too
little too late argument because if
you're asking for somebody to do
something and they do it and then you go
too late you're kind of being a jerk
right right well well they haven't done
it they haven't i think they just agree
well they just agreed to send from what
i heard the drones these uh
but by the way it's okay it's okay
because they just told me they did
it's a bipartisan push amy klobuchar she
says go get him in there right i had rob
portman of ohio geraldo on the show
today he said and i pulled the quote
because i mentioned it in the a block
it's something we should have done a
long time ago greg he said the state
department once said it had a green
light and suddenly it didn't we should
have sent them quietly in and gotten
those planes in there having ukrainian
pilots is not escalatory in my view you
know jesse to go back to your point
about god bless america what we are
sending in there it is amazing when you
go through the list you guys were
talking about all the anti uh aircraft
systems the 800 stingers going in the
2000 javelin 1000 light anti-armor
weapons that could go on i mean just
think about this though 20 million
rounds of small arms ammunition and
grenade launchers and mortar rounds 25
000 sets of body armor 25 000 helmets i
mean that is amazing uh what is going
into those ukrainians to fight on the
ground there but they still say they
need the air power well it could change
the
momentum with the siege of the capital
because if you have all of these tanks
that the russians have and they don't
even go off-road they stick to the main
roads because they can't run in mud and
you have all these stingers and javelins
and now these kamikaze drones you can
control remotely and you have insurgents
in the fields and the trees sneaking up
behind these columns of tanks you can
reign hell on these things and i don't
think the russians have any way to
defend against that and we gave him
radar so the minute they launch any
missile from the ground you can identify
that launch area and then just knock it
out forget about the migs the thing with
the migs is though nato has to all agree
that we're sending them remember that
hot potato with poland poland could have
gotten them there they're right on the
belarusian border right on the ukrainian
border so we didn't want to go because
none of nato wanted to go so we're not
going to unilaterally send migs at this
point but biden's under a lot of
pressure on the migs and i'm and i'm not
so sure we're not going to send jets
eventually because now as you said
democrats want to send weapons and once
uh
i think maybe once it gets warmer and
and italy and germany might not need as
much power might not need as much heat
and gas coming through these russian
pipelines they might get a little
tougher that's a really good point even
though that is a strange point
when it's cold right now
where are like where's europe germany is
just
awaking from a decades-long slumber well
we're okay we're also awaking from a
decade-long war
also true and we were both hesitant for
those opposing reasons you're absolutely
right i think the german giant
i mean how weird is it for people
especially my age to say oh isn't that
good news that germany is arming you
know that germany no one has ever said
that yeah no one has ever said that this
oh my god here comes germany when
germany and you haven't really seen the
french other than macron with his very
articulate and elegant nice photo photo
ops but when
so western europe really hasn't really
stepped up the way the united states is
stepping exactly let me say this about
the mix i wish they did it last night i
wish they did it the night before i
don't want to hear about it on
television uh you know they got other
migs that look just like them just paint
them the same way get them in there get
them flying eliminate it as an issue
because as you have all suggested
these switchblades these killer drones
they russia will rue the day
they will rue the day that they sent
those conscripts down there for those
killer drones silent
you know you don't see them
they go in your window
what do you think judge
well i think that the ukrainians
have made an incredible argument
uh that that they are militarily
superior to russia even without the
protection of the air because if you
read about it they had these these
turkish unmanned aerial vehicles which
can loiter over a tank and artillery and
everyone said they're old and they're
cheap and they use them with
devastatingly accurate missile fire the
ukrainians once they get this list of
weaponry that we've all been referencing
they're going to win this but when they
do win
what do they have they have a country
that's been destroyed they have a russia
has tried to take away their culture
their identity everything that they are
how do they build it back
but they've got a whole generation of
young people in their 20s who now have
to try to make a life out of a destroyed
country you see it's not enough to me
for putin to lose putin's got to be
punished for what he's done hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else